- I hear that you have a
special way of eating cupcakes
- I do.
- and I love cupcakes,
so I thought I would take
this opportunity selfishly
to bring cupcakes out
- Yes.
- and I wanna see your way.
- Okay.
- Is this,
thank you Justin, oh I'm
gonna be fancy, okay, okay.
- I did not,
very, very nice, thank you.
- I like red velvet.
- Wait, what was yours?
I'm red velvet.
- I just got, well
I'm kind of feeling I'm in a rainbow mood.
- Oh, I like it.
- Yeah.
- Rainbow sprinkles?
- I just feel like we
should all keep saying gay in Florida.
- Yeah.
- So we should wear
as much rainbow as possible
(audience cheering)
while that idiocy is being debated so.
- Wait, so I wanna know,
we're gonna suffer some commercials,
but I wanna know how you eat a cupcake,
'cause I hear you eat one differently
and I wanna learn Obi-Wan.
- Okay, so I didn't
realize that this was that
unusual until I at my friend,
- Okay.
- Steph's 40th birthday.
- And it got omicroned,
so we couldn't have a cake,
so we did a cup cakes.
- It got omicroned.
- It go omicroned
and so I took my cupcake
and I was sat there and we
were having a conversation
and I did this thing
and it stopped the party.
Now I have stopped parties before,
but never for a good reason
and this was a good way to stop a party.
So you take the top
- Oh
- and you pull it apart
and then you flip it.
(gasping)
- You like a, like a Whoopie Pie almost,
like you make it
to where it's like.
- And then you hae a sandwich
and you don't get frosting up your nose.
(audience cheering)
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
I didn't know,
I've never seen anyone do this,
but it reminds me like I
have a Whoopie Pie's are.
- I should have toasted
you before I took a bite.
Sorry about that,
I got hungry.
- I don't even know
if we're allowed to for COVID reasons,
so it's probably better.
It would be frowned upon.
- Ding, air ding.
- No and it's nicer too
'cause then you get like
the sandwich effect.
- And then you can just kind of,
and then it like feels more casual,
more like an hors d'oeuvres,
- Yeah.
- which all,
I just wanna make all desserts feel casual
(audience laughing)
so we can eat more of them.
- 'Cause they're so good.
I love this and I'm stealing it.